join the list of groups investigating
president Trump's former national
security adviser and his ties to Russia
retired General Michael Flynn was paid
about thirty four thousand dollars for a
speech in Moscow nearly 18 months ago
newly released pentagon documents show
that Flynn got an official letter months
earlier saying he could not receive fees
from a foreign government without
permission the White House press
secretary has had said that this has
nothing to do with the Trump
administration all of that clearance was
was made by the Obama during the Obama
administration and apparently with
knowledge of the trip that he took so
that's how the process works and I
welcome the Department of Defense's IG s
review congressman Elijah Cummings a
ranking Democrat on the House Oversight
Committee says there is no evidence that
Flynn told the Pentagon that the
Russians paid him with us now as the
United States attorney general Jeff
Sessions welcome good morning I know you
excused yourself and recused yourself
from some of the things that happened
during the campaign but having said that
did any of this information come to the
campaign during the campaign I'm not
aware of any of that and so I am recused
on those issues and anything that's
necessary to be done I'm sure will be
done but we in the Department of Justice
don't confirm or deny the existence of
investigations okay with regardless to
mr. Flynn is it is this kind of thing
and you're the nation's chief legal
officer a violation of the law i I don't
know enough about it to come in and I
think it'd be inappropriate for me to
comment on that what I would say is that
we have great cabinet members we've got
some people that are doing super jobs
like I was at the board of a general
Kelly Homeland Security last week we've
seen a 70% reduction in the number of
illegal entry so since our December at
the border that's a dramatic thing but
most exciting to see that I have let me
ask you this give I know that hindsight
is 20/20 but do you think the Trump
administration could have done a better
job in vetting mr. Flynn well these
things are not easy to discover if it
happened what happened I'm not sure it's
an impropriety or not I don't have an
opinion I would just say that they've
done a great
i'ma putting together some fabulous
people in the cabinet men and women of
integrity and good judgment but it would
be a mistake if he failed to reveal that
he had received this payment well I just
don't know enough to comment about I
don't think it's appropriate for me to
be talking about it let's turn out
immigration you pointed out the 70
percent drop in illegal crossings why do
you need a border wall well we're going
to need to get there we are on the verge
of creating what the American people
have wanted for 30 40 years which is a
lawful system of immigration one we
admit a million 11.1 million each year
to lawful permanent residents in the
United States in an appropriate way we
need to end the illegality I'll let
people apply got a Republican Congress I
mean this is so rare and they won't even
include new funding for this wall and
not one Republican lawmaker on those
four border states supports funding or
border wall we will get your own party
yeah we'll get funding for the wall and
it's important to do so I would just say
that this year we could use some money
this year but it's not critical because
that this year ends September 30th are
you getting what we need is next year
and and move forward yes get any funding
from Mexico as the president promised
there are a lot of ways that I think we
can fund the wall through in effect on
charges on those who enter the country
particularly all those who enter
unlawfully you've got a problem and and
the State Department has a problem they
don't have enough people to do the job
go ahead well we do have a hard time
getting people confirmed I've got 12
confirmed positions by the Senate only
one yesterday took office is my deputies
fabulous your fabric would have you
nominated somebody putting all of those
jobs virtually all our virtual a well a
good number of them I'm not sure whether
we over half yet or not but we have
others I'm not very having a problem
nominating it's not a problem
is just that you have to get FBI
backgrounds before you nominate them
people if you don't do the proper
vetting then you get accused of not
vetting before you nominate them and
good backgrounds are in portal let me
just ask you there's a lot in the news
about sexual harassment and Fox News
Channel we know that the Justice
Department is looking into that matter
and in fact it has expanded
this morning CBS News is reporting that
the US Postal Inspection Service also
looking into that
what is the investigation about I cannot
confirm or deny the existence of any
investigations those matters if they are
current will occur on their own but we
in the department don't talk about any
investigation again you're the chief
legal officer when the president
criticizes the Ninth Circuit in
significant ways is that a good idea
you look appropriate for the president
to consider mean to criticize the Ninth
Circuit well they're not above being
talked about you and was it right for
the president to do that it's right for
the President as he's done historically
over the centuries to express opinions
about judicial opinions then they have a
lifetime appointment their pay can't be
cut and their decisions can be coming in
on and these the one that he criticized
I think was wrong and I'm proud about
his new Supreme Court justice had some
reservations about the president
speaking to issues like this and
expressed it well attacking judges he
I'm not sure what he meant in that I see
one nominee recently said that well
we've got a lifetime appointment nothing
wrong with people coming about our
opinions and that's what I feel look the
judges in this country are so important
I respect them a practice before them
for many years as a federal prosecutor I
have the highest regard for them the
greatest threat to the independence of
the judiciary is if judges become more
political people cease to believe
they're deciding opinions based on laws
that would like to leave about the ninth
circuit judges I'm worried about it why
didn't work I do not I believe the
executive order the President issued was
carefully written in on sanctuary cities
were talking about sanctuary cities yes
the I was talking about the ablation
right no matter but that's the one that
was before the Ninth Circuit so I really
think that the judges just don't get
that sight well you said in the campaign
nine months ago so I don't like this
order so the question is there's the
order itself improper does it in any way
improper
they discriminate or does it so what do
you answer safety of America so what do
you and the president want to do about
the ninth circuit well I think we have a
number of judges in the country that
have departed a bit too far from
classical enforcing the law as written
they're using the law to advance an
agenda that they may have personally and
so the Ninth Circuit has been criticized
for that tendency more than any other
what should be done well the main thing
is your point judges and confirmed
judges to the Ninth Circuit that will be
responsible and more restrained in their
actions but you're not prohibited from
saying I disagree with what you're doing
else you've created a superior branch of
government we have three well what all
right mr. Froines Priebus called it says
the Night Circus is going bananas is
that illegal currently a legal term I'd
like to turn whether that our chief of
staff to the president mr. attorneys are
always good to have you here yeah thank
you come back thanks so much you very
much